the moral psychology the moral
philosophy and the politics standards I
mean so I mean so some facts about
people are we all have preferences we
have different preferences from each
other furthermore those preferences are
not things we all arrived at as
individuals right we we our preferences
are themselves products of social
coordination dynamics and different
people having different groups have
different histories and social
coordination dynamics then all the same
thing can be said again about the fact
that we all moralize some of our
preferences right and when you moralize
a preference you do treat it differently
when you treat a non moralized
preference even to even people who have
almost exactly the same preferences may
disagree on which preferences should be
moralized
furthermore it matters to all of us
which preferences other people moralize
because that'll affect the way they they
deal with us we have to do politics
around which preference around the
coordination of our preferences and we
also have to do politics and do do
politics around the moralization of our
preferences and both the formation of
preferences and the mobilisation of
other preferences of some of those
preferences both of those things are are
malleable in response to some extent in
response to consideration of
consequences so sometimes people will
change their preferences or drop a
moralization of a preference or more
lies something they didn't use - more or
less in light of facts that are made of
that they're made aware of that they
hadn't been made aware of but also
there's a very very strong aesthetic
component right so many of our moralize
preferences are based on judgments of
what seems to us to be attractive both
characters of people and characters of
certain kinds of acts and certain kinds
of lives and so on and all that's fair
game and the the complexity of the games
we play around the coordination over
both what preferences to have and what
preferences to more like the complexity
of those games is very very great but
we're most people are really quite good
at it
right but the the level of information
just in the sense that we're able to do
a great deal of computation
you